il ya quelques semaines il ya un nouveau
livre qui est sorti qui s'appelle
calling bullshit de carl barks trône et
je dois bien avouer que je ne vais pas
lui donc je n'aurai pas le contenu de
ses livres j'ai juste entend écouter une
interview de cartes berck forme est sûre
mindscape le podcast de shon carole et
je vois bien à vous que j'ai appris
assez négatif sur calling bullshit
même si je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
d'informations de très grande qualité à
l'intérieur de ce niveau de la recherche
de 30 ans qui a été fait
je crains que ce livre ne cherche à
davantage normalisé encore une pratique
que je trouve globalement très néfaste à
savoir cette envie de cole bullshit
d'utiliser mobile shit et la raison pour
laquelle je pense que juste utiliser mon
bol shit et néfaste il ya deux raisons
la première c'est que c'est quelque
chose d'incroyablement vire blanc fait
ainsi vous qualifier ce qu'a dit un
autre bullshit vous voir si vous
qualifier la personne de bullshit c'est
encore pire
bah forcément ce sera perçu comme une
attaque une attaque est même extrêmement
violente extrêmement glissante
voilà c'est mon cas pire chose à faire
que de dire quelqu'un bullshit un moment
lors d'un débat surtout si vous êtes en
désaccord avec cette personne
donc juste le propos colling bougies ça
me semble quelque chose d' extrêmement
néfastes surtout lors d'un débat et
surtout en face de la personne dont on
qualifie les propos de bullshit
bien sûr ça ne veut pas dire qu'il ne
faut pas souligné que certains propos
sont peu fiables complètement hors de
propos mais il me semble que bien le
faire mais c'est vrai bien content
déconstruire les yeux sans faire de
causer de réactance chez le public qui
est déjà convaincu par cet été et par
cette idée
c'est vraiment tout un art c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement difficile et
malheureusement l'habitude de juste dire
le mot bougies tout juste parfois de
souligner un sophisme par exemple avec a
dit l'autre bah ça montre tout le fossé
qu'il ya dans notre compréhension de
quelles sont les meilleures façons de
déconstruire des idées donc je suis en
vie et juste le titre nommé extrêmement
mal à l'aise et j'ai même envie d'aller
plus loin parce que dans le podcast en
tout cas carte beckstein défaut un peu
son livre en particulier de son
utilisation du mot bullshit par une
définition du mot brigitte il définit le
bushisme comme étant un propos qui se
moquent complètement de son statut de
vérité par opposition à un mensonge un
mensonge c'est là où sharks de là à dire
quelque chose aux autres que la vérité
alors que le bullshit
on s'en moque complètement de ce qu'est
la vérité
je pense que c'est une notion
intéressante et c'est intéressant de se
rendre compte que beaucoup des choses
qui sont dites notamment au poétique ne
correspondent pas à quelque chose dont
le statut de vérité est ce qui importe
souvent il s'agit plus de créer des
réactions de soulever un peu loose ligan
à la fois chez les opposants mais aussi
et surtout chez les personnes de l'autre
camp est donc souvent je pense que en
effet il ya beaucoup d'aspects de la
communication qui correspond à quelque
chose qui se désintéresse moins en
partie aux grandes parties parfois de du
statut de vérité deux de nos propos mais
je pense que ce qui est intéressant de
noter c'est que ce genre de choses c'est
absolument pas réservé à des méchants
politiciens genre j'en ai parlé
notamment dans ma vidéo sur l'honnêteté
intellectuelle
je pense que malheureusement le
bouchitey quelque chose d'extrêmement
récurrents tout cas à définir en tant
que tel notamment au sein de nous mêmes
pour nous mêmes j'ai l'impression qu'on
a beaucoup d'auto bullshit c'est à dire
on va souvent se cherchait à se
persuader de quelque chose sans se
demander si cette chose est vraiment
vrai l'exemple typique de ça c'est le
biais de confirmation
quand on pense quelque chose eh ben on
le défendre cette chose devient beaucoup
plus important que le statut de vérité
de cette chose et on peut sans lui à
avoir cet effet d'engagement qui fait
que du coup les propos que l'on a ou la
réflexion que l'on a n'est plus motivé
par une certaine recherche de cohérence
avec des données empiriques mais plus
par cette motivation de conforter ce
qu'on croyait déjà savoir notre exemple
de cela c'est présente la phrase de dire
j'ai envie de croire en l'humanité
si on dit je crois enfin j'ai envie de
croire à l'humanité encore plus il faut
croire en l'humanité
d'une certaine manière surtout si on se
met dans ses mots d'esprit où ça c'est
une vérité par des choux
d'une certaine manière on souhaite aux
moules frites puisqu'on dit cette phrase
sans ce
demander si elle a un rapport avec les
données empiriques et le monde tel qu'il
est donc cette notion de wichita vais
pas inintéressante mais elle est trop
connoté à mon sens est la meilleure
illustration de cela
heureusement c'est l'utilisation même du
mot bullshit un moment de l'interview
sur mindscape par karl d'extrême où il
qualifie de bullshit des propos tenus
par d'autres
j'ai l'impression que sa manière
d'utiliser le mot bronchite et elle-même
du bullshit
c'est à dire que lorsqu'il dit le mot
bullshit il ne cherche pas à mon sens
entre phil ivey impression suffisamment
à comprendre ce que veut vraiment dire
le côté opposé et en particulier là bas
et je pense qu'un argument pour dire que
le côté opposé ne se moque pas
complètement en tout cas du du statut la
verite de vérité de ce qu'il dit est à
l' inverse
j'ai l'impression que avoir utilisé
lorsqu'il utilise nos bus site
kardex trang est en situation de
bullshit dans le sens où son utilisation
du mot bullshit n'est pas motivée par le
statut de vérité de son qualificatif de
bullshit serre lorsqu'ils utilisent un
mobile shit ils se demandent pas est ce
que la personne a vraiment sorti un
bogie il utilise plus haut niveau shit
pour tourner en dérision pour gagner
finalement le coeur d d d auditeurs et
convaincre les auditeurs que ce que dit
l'autre et ne mérite aucun aucune
attention
et alors bon on peut dire que c'est un
seul exemple et que j'ai tiré piqué
n'est pas très bien car d'accès mais
j'ai entendu juste dans cette interview
le fait d'avoir sorti un vous fîtes sur
le mot brigitte au cours d'interviews
vraiment pas mal je frappe et peut-être
qu'il fait passe encore mais ça
m'étonnerait
ça m'étonnerait mais peut-être que je
j'ai exagéré un peu trop par contre ce
qui me semble assez clair c'est que le
mobile shit ou d'autres notions
similaires sont user et abuser par
beaucoup de personnes qui cherche à
dénoncer le bullshit 6e d'importance
donnée au statut de vérité par leur côté
opposé et en cela en fait juste le
l'envi de qualification de bullshit
pouces nous-mêmes ou brigitte du coup
j'ai envie de vous encourager
d'encourager et de vous encourage
encourager les autres à ne pas utiliser
de mots aussi si agressif et qui pousse
autant à l'auto bullshit et au lieu de
ça constamment cherché à mieux
comprendre le compte de côté opposé et
s'il dit des choses qui vous paraissent
très être erronées a cherché à faire de
preuve d'énormément de bienveillance et
de pédagogie
lorsque vous cherchez à déconstruire les
idées du côté opposé aux yeux des du
côté opposé
et même aux yeux de vos propres
communautés
enfin si vous voyez quelqu'un qui
utilise l'adjectif bullshit à mauvais
escient ou des choses similaires
je vous invite à essayer d'être calme et
bienveillant envers cette personne aussi
c'est pas facile de se rendre compte que
ce qu'on dit est contre-productif
nuisibles et il faut beaucoup de
beaucoup de bienveillance pour vous
compte pour convaincre quiconque que ce
qui est persuadé de faire pour le bien
est en fait possiblement pas si et
productive voire néfaste pour le bien il
faut beaucoup de tacles et de pédagogie
et j'aimerais que ces mots hacked
pédagogie bienveillance soit beaucoup
plus mise en avant que des objectifs que
des adjectifs comme bullshit par exemple